bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle édition de 24 heures Sénats
vous êtes en direct sur public c'est la
voici le programme de votre après-midi
dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre l'audition de Louis Gallois il
est entendu parler sénateurs sur son
rapport sur le pacte de compétitivité
pour l'industrie française puis à 18h15
prof par 3 l'émission politique de la
rédaction qui reçoit aujourd'hui Laurent
Wauquiez ancien ministre des affaires
européennes et députés UMP de la
Haute-Loire et puis on se retrouve à 19h
pour 24 heures Sénat le journal on
parlera de la polémique du jour autour
de ces nouvelles rames de TER trop large
qui nécessite 50 millions d'euros de
travaux le sénateur UMP de la Manche
jean Bizet présenté aujourd'hui son
rapport sur la coopération énergétique
franco-allemande et il a rappelé les
besoins de la France en énergie peu
coûteuse estimant qu'il ne fallait pas
fermer la porte au gaz de schiste on
l'écoute au micro de Jérôme Bonnard
si nous voulons réindustrialiser
l'Europe ce à quoi nous invite fort
justement la commission ça ne peut se
concevoir qu'avec une énergie maîtrisée
et pas chère toute proportion gardée
dans une conjoncture économique qui fait
que l'irruption du gaz de schiste de
l'autre côté de l'Atlantique à modifier
précisément le paysage énergétique
mondial avec une énergie là encore
toujours de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
beaucoup moins cher
le président du groupe PS au Sénat
affirme que les sénateurs UMP devront
s'expliquer sur les soupçons de
détournement frauduleux des dotations
versées à leur groupe information
révélées hier par le journal Le Parisien
ce n'est pas bon pour la politique ce
n'est pas bon pour la démocratie ce
n'est pas bon pour le Sénat à expliquer
d'idée Guillaume devant l'Association
des Journalistes parlementaires en
séance les sénateurs débattent cette
après-midi du climat et de l'énergie en
Europe débat à la demande du groupe
écologiste du Sénat on reviendra sur ces
questions dans le journal de 19h je vous
disais les sénateurs poursuivre leurs
auditions sur l'impact des exonérations
de cotisations sociales sur l'emploi et
ils entendent cet après-midi Louis
Gallois pour en parler tome training a
rejoint sur ce plateau bonjour Thom
bonjour Delphine alors quel est l'enjeu
de cette audition ben écoutez ils
écoutent donc Louis Gallois c'est le
monsieur compétitivité de François
Hollande un homme de gauche et un esprit
libre un entrepreneur anciens présidents
de Hadès qui n'a pas créé en 2012 de
faire des propositions pas très
orthodoxes pour un homme de gauche dans
son rapport sur la compétitivité les
réclamaient alors un choc de
compétitivité de 30 milliards d'euros
pour redonner des marges de manœuvre un
ballon d'oxygène aux entreprises et pour
cela établer sur des allègements de
charge patronales et salariales alors un
an et demi plus tard où est-ce qu'on en
est et bien il y a eu l'annonce du pacte
de responsabilité par François Hollande
lors de ses vœux est repris par Manuel
Valls aussitôt nommé Premier ministre il
a défendu ce pack de responsabilité il
l'a défendu comme un chantier essentiel
et il va bien y avoir un ballon
d'oxygène pour les entreprises de 30
milliards d'euros mais 20 milliards vont
provenir du cice le fameux crédit
d'impôt compétitivité et 10 milliards
viennent des allègements de charge c'est
à ça que s'intéresse la mission du Sénat
qu'est-ce que qu'elle va être l'effet
pour les entreprises est-ce qu'on doit
en attendre des résultats rapides pour
l'emploi ou simplement en matière
d'investissement c'est ce que cherche
donc à déterminer cette mission
d'information en écoutant aujourd'hui
lougawa cette mission d'information qui
je le précise a été constituée à la
demande du groupe communiste merci
beaucoup thème alors sans plus tarder
direction la salle Médicis pour suivre
cette audition et on se retrouve juste
après
dans mon rapport je ne traitais pas des
problèmes de l'emploi tout au moins par
court terme
je traitais les pommes de la
compétitivité
qui est génératrice d'emploi moyen terme
mais qui n'a pas
qui qui ne vise pas a priori à créer de
l'emploi immédiatement
on sait là je sans être économétré il y
a une intuition qui rejoint les études
c'est que lorsque l'on cible les
réductions de charge sur les bas
salaires
on a un effet emploi
assez fort
mais qui est réparti sur l'ensemble du
champ des acteurs économiques y compris
ceux qui emploient beaucoup de monde qui
ne sont pas le temps exposés à la
concurrence internationale
les grandes surfaces et autres
en revanche si on
privilégie des emplois aussi ont permis
des exonérations
portant sur
des rémunérations plus élevées en
diminue l'impact sur l'emploi et on
normalement
on a un impact plus ciblé sur
l'industrie qui elle-même les plus
exposée à la concurrence internationale
donc on cible plus l'impact sur le les
l'industrie
j'avais d'ailleurs expliqué que
les allègements que je proposais qui
portaient sur les charges sociales et
pas sur le crédit d'impôt mais enfin
c'est du second ordre
visé surtout à donner un ballon
d'oxygène aux entreprises
pour
les remettre dans une dynamique
d'investissement
et j'avais donc souhaité que ça soit
ciblé plutôt sur l'industrie pour ça que
j'avais proposé que ça soit au moins
jusqu'à trois fois et demi le SMIC
et le gouvernement comme vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs fort justement je ne peux
paraphraser vos propos a choisi une
solution moyenne entre les deux
avec deux fois et demi de Smic
avec un effet coupé
c'est à dire que une rémunération qui
est de deux fois à 6 le SMIC n'a droit
aucun allégement ce qui
m'a toujours posé question
j'aurais préféré que l'on ait
au moins que mais bien évidemment ça a
croisé le coup de la mesure mais que
l'exonération de la réduction de charges
soit acquise
de toute façon en dessous de ce seuil de
fois et demi et la partie de la
rémunération au-dessus de fois et demi
non bénéficiant pas
alors on peut aborder le sujet de deux
manières
la première c'est celle qui résulte
d'une étude que la dg6 c'est-à-dire les
services de Monsieur Montebourg ont
demandé au professeur zagame je ne sais
pas si c'est ces travaux ont été portés
à votre attention si bon
si on transféré la totalité des charges
des allocations familiales 32 milliards
à la charge des entreprises actuellement
si on les transféré la totalité sur la
fiscalité
l'effet serait de
62000 créations d'emplois
et on a croit très
cet effort si on le se résultat en
termes de création d'emploi si on le
focalisait plus sur les bas salaires
je vais vous dire que je suis incapable
de vérifier ce chiffre
de 62
000 emplois
il est en tout cas fondé sur une
hypothèse de croissance qui est décisive
et j'en viens à ma deuxième
aspect qui est
d'examiner ce café l'impact du cice
là je pense que vous avez bénéficié des
travaux du de l'Insee fait à la demande
du commissariat général stratégie et à
la prospective
une enquête sur 8000 entreprises à peu
près la moitié de ces entreprises ont
répondu
et vous connaissez le résultat les
entreprises ayant droit à plusieurs
réponses ça fera plus de 100% mais 46 %
l'affectent à la croissance de
l'investissement
31% à l'emploi 21% au prix à la baisse
du prix de vente et 20% l'augmentation
des salaires dans l'industrie et dans
les services c'est 53% à la croissance
de l'investissement 43% à l'emploi
29% la baisse du prix de vente et 38% à
l'augmentation des salaires je déduis
d'ailleurs de ce de répondre
questionnaire que les gens du service
ont très mal répondu ils ont dit oui à
tout
ils ont coché toutes les cases
et donc je ne trouve pas ça très
pertinent du côté des services je vous
le dis comme je le pense
et encore une fois je ne suis pas un
économène mais je dois un peu suspect
que de voir que
ils ont répondu pratiquement oui à
toutes les avec un petit bémol sur la
réduction des prix de vente
ce qui d'ailleurs n'est pas surprenant
pour les services puisqu'ils sont peu
exposés à la compétition internationale
je suis plus sensible à ce que répondu
l'industrie qui m'a paru avoir été un
peu plus sélective
mais alors on constate qu'en gros un
tiers des entreprises un gros tiers des
entreprises
affecteront le bénéfice du cice à la
création d'emploi si on en lit si ou
tout au moins d'une partie de de
l'avantage c'est ici à la création
d'emploi
je dois vous dire que pour moi je ne
crois absolument pas aux effets
mécaniques
les entreprises embaucheront si elles
ont un certain degré de confiance dans
la croissance
qui leur permettra
de nourrir ses emplois
on constate d'ailleurs que si les
entreprises sont optimistes sur la
conjoncture
elle répond
beaucoup plus positivement sur la
création d'emplois 15 points de plus sur
la consommation d'emploi que les
entreprises qui sont qui ont un jugement
négatif sur la conjoncture donc là
conjoncture introduit un élément
absolument décisif dans la création
d'emploi
je retire de cela mais peut-être me
tromper
que l'effet le plus solide du cice va
quand même être sur l'investissement
et que le reste est beaucoup plus
aléatoire et dépend vraiment de la
conjoncture économique
et d'ailleurs ça ne me déplaît pas parce
que c'était quand même ce que je
souhaitais lorsque j'ai proposé la
mesure c'est peut-être pour ça
d'ailleurs que je tire les statistiques
de ce côté là donc j'ai peut-être un
billet mais là je constate quand même
que c'est ce qui est le plus solide
c'est l'investissement qui les
perspectives sur l'investissement
bougent beaucoup moins en fonction de la
conjoncture que les perspectives sur
l'emploi qui qui prend une surprise est
beaucoup plus dépendant de de de la
situation économique de l'entreprise
surtout de ces perspectives de
croissance
je peux pas aller beaucoup plus loin
sauf à déborder largement le sujet et
aborder tous les problèmes de la
compétitivité vous m'avez vous m'avez
demandé d'aborder le problème du
dialogue social c'est à notre sujet je
suis tout à fait prêt à le faire
je
c’était à la fois incidemment mais
peut-être mourrez-vous à l'occasion
d'une autre question
en tout cas pour répondre sur ce sujet
qui m'a toujours intéressé
maintenant je sais oui
bien donc je vous remercie tout d'abord
ce prix là et donc je vais passer la
parole à notre rapporteur madame de
médecine qui je pense va vous voir aller
plus loin un peu il va vous pousser dans
vos retranchements peut-être oui
toute façon on est intéressé aussi par
le concept de compétitivité puisque
c'est quand même
par ricochet c'est quand même le sujet
que nous abordons
donc je vais revenir sur la question que
vous avez abordé vous avez répondu en
partie mais on peut peut-être un petit
peu la creuser dans votre célèbre
rapport on peut le dire de novembre 2012
sur la compétitivité vous avez écrit et
je vous cite les allègrements effectués
depuis 20 ans concernent les plus basse
à l'air et ont pour cette raison très
peu impacté directement l'industrie qui
se situe à des rémunérations plus
élevées vous venez de le rappeler pour
atteindre de manière privilégier
l'industrie et les services et autres
fois la rajouter qui lui sont liées
bureau d'études ingénierie informatique
conseil il conviendrait que le transfert
de charge porte sur les salaires jusqu'à
trois fois et demi le SMIC dans ces
conditions vous avez dit à l'époque 35%
de l'avantage créé iraient directement
vers l'industrie et les services à haute
valeur ajoutée associées alors
estimez-vous que le cice
combiné au récentes annonce
gouvernementales vont dans ce sens je
pense que
vous l'avez un peu dit en rajoutant que
vous espériez qu'ils aillent à
l'investissement et il semblerait que
c'est plutôt vers ce sens encore que
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas encore
l'affirmer
et dans les auditions et je rajoute et
dans les auditions que nous avons eu
notamment avec la BPI qui est le la
banque de prêt-financement
dans les demandes de préfinancement qui
sont pas
qui reflètent pas complètement
le
comportement mais
globalement
une grande partie s'est pré-financements
l'ont été demandées pour répondre à des
problèmes de trésorerie
donc il y a aussi cet aspect là qui me
faut qu'il faut prendre en compte
surtout quand la situation continue à ne
pas aller très bien ça c'est la première
question
deuxièmement dans le même temps vous
avez souligné les effets dit de second
tour en vertu desquels un allègement de
charge sur les bases à l'air a pour
conséquence une amélioration de la
compétitivité et des secteurs à salaire
élevés en raison de la baissement
général des coûts de production donc on
entend bien ça mais est-il possible de
quantifier ses effets
troisième question à quelles conditions
les exonérations de charges sociales
peuvent-elles constituer un levier
efficace pour permettre une montée en
gamme ne se trompe-t-on pas de combat
dès lors que la montée en gamma
industrielle devrait nous conduire à
raisonner en compétitivité hors prix
dans les autres pays notamment
l'Allemagne c'est un sujet qui revient
tous les jours de manière récurrente
quelles ont été les leviers sociaux et
fiscaux utilisés pour favoriser depuis
20 ans cet appareil industriel à forte
valeur ajoutée vous avez certainement un
avis sur cette question et enfin
des dispositifs incitatifs sur le plan
fiscal comme des armortissements
dérogatoires ou le crédit d'impôt
recherche ne sont-ils pas plus adaptés
peut-on mesurer l'impact sur l'emploi
direct et du Crédit Impôt Recherche et
qualifieront qualifierez vous la France
comme on le lit parfois de paradis
fiscal pour la recherche
première salle et puis on abordera après
ensuite les questions de la
compétitivité parce que ça nous
intéresse
je maintiens
ce que je vous ai dit c'est à dire que
si on veut focaliser sur l'esprit la
courbe je l'ai pas apporté mais je sais
pas porté mais elle j'en dispose la
courbe qui mesure
l'impact sur l'industrie en fonction du
seuil qui est retenu du niveau maximum
d'exonération
on plafonne à trois quand on est à trois
à trois et demi fois le SMIC on a une
une part de l'industrie qui que j'ai
chiffré à peu près à 35% et qui
n'augmente plus vraiment on passe
peut-être si on allait à six fois on
passerait peut-être de 35 à 37% on est
près de la symptômes comme on dirait en
mathématiques alors que entre deux fois
et demi et trois fois et demi il y a une
grosse différence assez nette j'ai pas
le chiffre en tête mais je dirais
qu'avec deux fois et demi on est plutôt
autour de 25% qu'Auto 35%. mais ceci
mériterait d'être vérifié et je ne veux
pas m'engager sur ce chiffre donc je
reste convaincu que si on veut traiter
le problème de la compétitivité des
secteurs exposés à la concurrence et du
secteur industriel auquel je suis
particulièrement attaché parce que
j'estime que c'est la fine pointe de la
compétitivité d'un pays
je pense que il fallait il faudrait
aller au-delà de fois et demi le SMIC
et l'intérêt d'un transfert des
allocations familiales
même si il y a des plafonnement c'est
que ça touche tous les salaires
et donc je trouvais que c'était mieux
adapté d'autant plus que
sur le plan théorique faire supporter à
l'appareil de production
des éléments de solidarité nationale qui
relèvent normalement de l'impôt comme
les la politique de la famille ne me
paraissait pas
totalement ça me paraissait pas
totalement justifié de le faire porter
par les entreprises
quant au soleil a été créé en 45 il y
avait la capacité contributive n'était
que dans les entreprises et donc on a
pris cette base parce que c'était celle
qui existait
je pense que actuellement la fiscalité
c'est
suffisamment diversifiée pour que on
puisse s'envisager d'autres d'autres
supports
vous avez raison de dire que le crédit
d'impôt d'abord le crédit d'impôt le
cice c'est bien joli mais les
entreprises ne l'ont pas encore touché
c'est sur le premier acompte de l'impôt
sur les sociétés que ça va commencer à
être déduit donc c'est ces jours-ci donc
ce qu'elle les entreprises il y a des
endroits qui ont fait appel auprès de
financement et vous l'avez madame la
rapporteur souligné
les entreprises qui font appel auprès de
financement sont celles qui ont des
besoins de trésorerie puisque ce
préfinancement écoute
vous n'avez peut-être pas demandé à la
BPI qui a été le taux d'intérêt sur ce
préfinancement
et bien écoutez ce n'est pas ce qui est
vérifié dans les provinces où on me
donne des chiffres plus élevés et qui en
plus dépendent à ce que ce n'est pas oui
pardon oui 2 à 4 selon la taille des
entreprises et donc quand vous avez une
inflation à 0 quand vous avez une
inflation à 0,5 07
ce sont des taux d'intérêts qui ne sont
pas négligeables donc les entreprises
qui ont des trésorerie ne font pas appel
auprès de financement ce sont celles qui
ont des besoins de financement donc je
dirais que c'est presque la
démonstration que ce sont les
entreprises on a des problèmes de
trésorerie et effectivement pour une
entreprise
les problèmes de trésorerie sont passe
avant tous les autres
quand une autorises n'a plus de
trésorerie elle ne peut plus vivre donc
dès lors qu'il y a des problèmes de
trésorerie tout est bon pour alimenter
cette trésorerie y compris le
préfinancement du ses yeux parce que les
entreprises ont des bonnes trésorerie
quand elle va banquier ou ça avec les
banquiers quand il fait beau pas quand
il pleut
je le reprendrai pas cette expression
dans un procès-verbal parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'amusants qui aimaient
on voit bien qu'actuellement les
entreprises ont quelques difficultés à
se financer actuellement j'ai compris
d'ailleurs que Monsieur Montebourg les
avait réunis pour leur demander de
d'être plus actif dans ce domaine
voilà ce que je veux vous répondre sur
la première
question sur la quantification des
effets encore une fois
l'effet sur l'emploi à mon avis est très
dépendant du taux de croissance que l'on
retient
et l'effet sur l'investissement
il faudrait savoir tout le problème dans
ces affaires là c'est de connaître la
base c'est qu'est-ce qui serait passé
s'il y avait pas de crédit s'il y avait
pas eu le cice
je
s'il y a une augmentation de
l'investissement en 2014 ce que les
économistes prévoient
quelle part devra être attribue aussi
c'est défenseurs vont lui attribuer une
part importante
d'autres peut-être moins je constate
néanmoins que c'est le sujet le thème
qui est le plus retenu par les
entreprises des services et de
l'industrie lorsqu'on demande ce qu'ils
vont faire du CIC
j'ai noté d'ailleurs qu'on leur posait
pas la question de savoir s'il est
redistribué à leurs actionnaires mais
bon il y avait on leur a posé quatre
questions parce que on aurait pu leur
poser une cinquième bon donc je suis pas
capable de vous répondre si ce n'est ces
éléments qui me conduisent à penser que
ça peut soutenir l'investissement
vous dites l’exonération je cherche
sociale traite un problème de
compétitivité coût et la montée en gamme
c'est hors coût pour monter en gamme il
faut investir
il faut investir il y a deux sujets dans
l'industrie française actuellement qui
sont un obstacle à la croissance
potentielle de la France c'est d'abord
des gains de productivité très faibles
nous avons une bonne productivité mais
cette productivité siraude du fait que
les gains de productivité annuelles sont
très faibles actuellement parce que les
entreprises n'investissent pas assez
c'est devenu maintenant un lieu commun
que de dire que nous avons 35000 robots
en France que
l'italien n'a 62000 et l'Allemagne 150
000 et que les générations de robots en
France sont plus anciennes que les
générations de robots en Italie et en
Allemagne
je pense qu'il y a un gain les gains de
productivité ont été
insuffisants parce que l'investissement
est insuffisant les deuxièmement
l'innovation
est un élément aussi de monter en gamme
et de et de d'augmentation de la
croissance potentielle et l'innovation
coûte de l'argent
il faut dépenser de l'argent pour
innover parce qu'il faut faire de la
recherche etc
donc la montée en gamme c'est hors coût
c'est vrai c'est même pour sortir de la
du piège des prix
on n'achète pas une BMW parce qu'elle
est bon marché
est-ce que pour être un peu abrupte la
problématique que l'on a en France
je veux dire entre ceux créations
d'emplois ou compétitivité etc ne
repose-t-elle pas sur le fait que nous
avons une spécificité c'est à dire que
nous avons un SMIC relativement fort et
qui est quand même en marché que tout
notre système social et quand même ainsi
sur la partie salaire et donc comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure sur les
entreprises et que de surcroît son
niveau de protection sociale et en plus
très haut ce dont on ne va pas se
plaindre mais il est assis là-dessus et
alors est-ce que en fait toutes les
solutions qu'on essaie de discuter ne
sont pas quelques fois là pour compenser
cet état de choses dans un monde un
petit peu globalisé
de l'élément cool la compétitivité
et évidemment
quand on parle d'exonération de charges
sociales de réduction de la fiscalité
sur les entreprises c'est pour traiter
ce point de de l'élément de coût alors
toutes les comparaisons internationales
existent sur ces éléments de coûts sur
le coup du travail etc moi je me suis
gardé d'aborder ce problème sous
l'aspect coût du travail
parce que pourquoi je réparer du coup il
travaille et pas du coup de la fiscalité
du coût de l'énergie
j'ai seulement dit je constate que les
marges des entreprises sont extrêmement
basses
je constate que les maladies sont
extrêmement basses et qu'elles ont
besoin de ballon d'oxygène à la fois
pour retrouver confiance et pour
réenclencher un processus
d'investissement
c'est comme cela que je l'ai présenté
vous ne trouverez pas dans mon rapport
l'expression coup du travail ce qui veut
pas dire que je considère pas que ça
soit pas un problème
mais je me suis dit si je parle du coup
du travail il faut que je parle de tous
les coups et pas uniquement du coup du
travail les coûts financiers les coûts
les coûts fiscaux etc donc
je j'ai bien parlé de ballon d'oxygène
pour les entreprises
et
toute ma thèse c'est qu'il faut
justement
sortir
une partie de l'industrie française
de de
d'un d'une compétition par les prix
qui l'étrangle
et pour sortir de la compétition par des
prix il faut créer d'autres avantages
que le prix
c'est ce que l'industrie allemande a
fait magnifiquement sur lesbiens
d'équipement on achète des biens
d'équipements parce qu'il y en a pas
d'autres
les automobiles allemandes sont plus
chers je vous donne un exemple
entre une Volkswagen et une voiture
française
à
caractéristique égale la Volkswagen
coûte 10% plus cher
parce que les gens veulent acheter une
Volkswagen
et c'est cet élément qu'il faut qu'on
soit capable de créer en France sur nos
sur nos productions
sans travers de ce cri il y a une
entreprise française qui est un bon
exemple c'est Michelin Michelin vont ses
pneus plus cher que les autres
et on achète les pneus Michelin parce
qu'on va avoir des pneus Michelin parce
qu'on sait que sont les meilleurs
mais vous imaginez l'avantage que ça
donne à une entreprise dans la
compétition internationale de pouvoir
vendre plus cher que les autres
et je pense que c'est ça que nous devons
essayer alors je dis pas que ça pourra
concerner la totalité de l'industrie
mais ça peut
intéresser
des secteurs beaucoup plus larges de
notre industrie
sur les leviers fiscaux et sociaux en
Allemagne
il y a des éléments sur le levier
fiscaux
la fiscalité des entreprises et un
niveau plus bas que la fiscalité
française fiscalité charge sociale
assez sensiblement plus bas toutes les
calculs ont été faits je vais pas les
refaire
ce qui veut dire que les ménages à
l'inverse payent plus c'est pareil pour
l'électricité il y a un transfert de
l'électricité des tarifs de du coût de
l'électricité en Allemagne des
entreprises vers les ménages
ceci est facilité par une chose
c'est que le logement représente 16% du
revenu des Allemands et 26% de revenus
des Français
et je pense que nous avons j'ai regretté
je l'ai dit plusieurs fois de ne pas
avoir traité ce problème dans mon
rapport je l'ai
omis c'est-à-dire c'est une
erreur de ma part parce que je pense que
c'est un élément tout à fait décisif qui
fait que les ménages français leur
capacité contributive j'allais dire ce
pot pour autre chose pour l'énergie pour
la fiscalité pour autre chose et limitée
par le fait qu'il consomme énormément
pour le logement
avec un coût du logement qui est
handicap pour l'ensemble de la société
française
alors ça les Allemands ont mieux résolu
ce problème que nous quand sur le plan
social l'Allemagne a créé à la suite des
formats deux marchés du travail
complètement séparés
un premier marché du travail qui est
celui
des grandes entreprises ou des
entreprises du métal chef du Mittal
stand avec des organisations syndicales
extrêmement puissantes que j'ai pu
mesurer
quand vous avez une grève chez Airbus
Hambourg il y avait 98% de grévistes
c'est à dire que tout le monde est en
grève ça s'arrête tout s'arrête
donc vous avez des syndicats forts qui
ont établi un rapport de force avec les
organisations patronales fondées sur un
dialogue social beaucoup plus riche
qu'en France
nous y voilà beaucoup plus riche qu'en
France et qui qui à mon avis
gagnant-gagnant je le dis franchement
mais qui concerne une partie du salariat
et ce qu'introduit art dans ces réformes
c'est un deuxième partie une
précarisation totale d'une partie du
monde du travail avec des contrats
évidemment à temps par beaucoup de temps
partiel
beaucoup pas de salaire minimum des
salaires des des
salaires extrêmement bas qui sont entre
1 et 4 5 euros
ce qui conduit d'ailleurs les
collectivités territoriales à faire le
complément j'appelle ça de la subvention
à l'industrie moi
l'économie parce que quand vous payez un
salarié dans les abattoirs allemands 4
euros et que ce salarié pour rejoindre
les deux bouts est obligé de demander
l'aide sociale à la collectivité à la
collectivité
c'est une sorte de subvention indirecte
aux abattoirs allemands
il faut pas s'étonner si nos
abattoirs eux qui sont soumis à la dur
loi monsieur le Président que vous
évoquiez du salaire minimum
bon donc vous avez
et ça c'est un avantage considérable
c'est un avantage considérable parce que
ça ne concerne pas l'industrie ça ne
concerne pas l'industrie exportatrice
les abattoirs étant une exception ça
concerne mais ça concerne des secteurs
qui font que
les produits
ça réduit c'est un avantage indirect
pour l'industrie parce que ça crée un
environnement de service et de produits
bon marché dont bénéficient les
entreprises ou les salariés des
entreprises
et tricher par exemple me disait
tu peux pas savoir on est rue de
Francfort la vie est moins cher qu'à
Paris que dans les villes françaises
je pense qu'une des raisons pour
lesquelles c'est moins cher c'est parce
que une partie des salaires sont situés
très en dessous de ce que nous appelons
c'est un minimum et d'ailleurs c'est
pour cela que on va regarder avec
beaucoup d'attention ce que font les
Allemands sur le salaire minimum et
comment il va être mis en place dans les
différentes branches
mauvais interrogé ensuite sur
les des mesures plus ciblées en faveur
d'industrie par exemple
l'amortissement accéléré ou
un traitement fiscal privilégié des
investissements etc on peut tout à fait
l'imaginer je dois vous dire que lorsque
j'avais évoqué mais dans mon rapport les
allègements cette question avait été
venue j'en avais eu l'occasion d'en
débattre avec telle ou tel sur ce sujet
j'avais préféré une mesure générale
visible qui parce que je pensais qu'il
fallait créer un effet un petit effet de
choc et que je pensais que on le créait
mieux à travers une mesure générale qu'à
travers des mesures partielles mais ceci
est tout à fait tout à fait
discuté et le débat est réel moi je suis
assez favorable à l'amortissement
accéléré des investissements
le crédit d'impôt recherche
j'en suis un défenseur acharné
avec une théorie qui est
enfin qui est fondée sur mon expérience
qui est que
pour les petites entreprises alors a
permis de maintenir l'effort de
recherche pendant la crise à un niveau
correct et vous savez que les
entreprises françaises
dépensent au moins autant en recherche
un secteur donné taille donné que les
entreprises allemandes ou autres
et c'est alors qu'elles ont des marges
beaucoup plus basses basses c'est
largement dû au crédit d'impôt recherche
et quant aux grandes entreprises
le seul l'impact
en France et pas ailleurs
et je peux vous dire que ça a été le cas
de
nous sommes nous avons implanté des
activités de recherche en France
grâce au crédit d'impôt recherche on n'a
pas fait plus de recherches à cause de
ça mais on a fait en France parce qu'il
y a une véritable compétition
internationale sur la localisation des
centres de recherche actuellement
et que les Anglais particuliers débroule
le tapis rouge
sur
pour attirer les centres de recherche
des entreprises et je pense que c'est un
élément dans la compétition
internationale
vous avez employé l'expression paradis
fiscal pour la recherche vous êtes
peut-être aller un peu loin monsieur le
Président mais
parce que le paradis fiscal je ne je le
ferai je dirais que c'est un paradis
fiscal pour la bonne cause à la
différence d'autres paradis fiscaux
donc on va passer une première série de
questions alors qui souhaite madame
madame linmann et ensuite monsieur le
Montesquieu et Monsieur bon je vous en
prie allez-y
monsieur Gallois moi je j'apprécie
beaucoup ce que vous avez dit notamment
dans votre rapport sur le hors-cou et
puisque vous avez été vous-même
à une responsabilité majeure avec le
Haut Commissariat à l'industrie c'est ça
le choix le nom à l'investissement
pardon
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que la
France dans le recours
à maintenant fait un effort substantiel
qui devrait est-ce qu'il y a pas sur ce
champ là encore beaucoup à faire et ça
m'amène à la deuxième question c'est
qu'on avait eu ce débat sur les mesures
générales le coup électrochoc par
rapport à la et je préfère votre
présentation sur un booster pour
restaurer des marges plutôt qu'une
théorie générale de la baisse des coûts
du travail
néanmoins est-ce que il y aurait pas eu
de convaincre
mais justement ce qui me préoccupe c'est
que est-ce que les 35 milliards qu'on a
mis dans le cice enfin normalement c'est
plus c'est logement est-ce qu'il y
aurait pas été plus opportun parce qu'on
regarde que la part industrie est quand
même assez faiblement je parle pas que
de l'industrie pur je pense du service à
l'industrie même si on peut dire qu'un
balayeur d'une entreprise de balayage
c'est un service à l'industrie mais
enfin ça impacte quand même modérément
les coûts est-ce que il y aurait pas eu
plus d'intérêt à mettre cet argent sur
des stratégies de filière
d'accompagnement de stratégie de filière
en mutation d'investissement et en
particulier sur les plans de
rebaptisation du pays parce qu'en plus
le fait qu'on cible nous aide sur des
catégories salariales plutôt en bas
finalement n'est pas tellement
incitatif à faire l'arbitrage
modernisation ou plutôt que salaire
et en tout cas investissement donc là
vous est déjà dit les amortissements
accélérés mais ce qu'il y a d'autres
formes d'aide
qui auraient par exemple mettre de
l'argent de la BPI la BPI nous indique
finalement pour les prêts comme on
appelle ça les prénoms durée à
faiblement là comment ils appellent ça
des prêts ils nous ont donné un peu un
non technique pour des prêts de
développement
un peu solide dans la durée quoi je sais
plus c'est un nom il semble qu'il manque
de crédit pour ce type de prêt est-ce
qu'il aurait pas été plus utile de
transférer une partie des sommes de la
BPI est-ce que c'est pas là qu'il
faudrait mettre des aides
complémentaires et je termine
sur l'expérience qu'a fait Obama des
manufactories alors le plan américain de
relance de l'industrie manufacturière et
il est quand même fondé sur toute une
série d'activités eux ils arrivent à
différencier leurs aides fiscales et
sociales en fonction des secteurs
industriels or une déteste en France et
on peut pas parce que il y a de la
concurrence on n'a pas le droit de faire
des aides mais ne pourrions-nous pas
avoir des aides sélectives et de ce
point de vue le crédit pour recherche a
quand même une grande sélectivité
industrielle même si les banques etc
est-ce qu'il y aurait pas la possibilité
d'avoir pour une partie des aides
fiscales ou des des allègements de
cotisation une
des contreparties qui soit adossée à des
contrats de filière à des conventions de
filière c'est à dire si je puis dire
avoir une règle générale c'est que si on
signe une convention de développement
industriels ou truc à ce moment là des
allégements de charge ils sont
conditionnés ce qui à ce moment-là
permet quand même de cibler là où on
veut atteindre des objectifs en commun
deuxième chose qui a dans le plan
américain c'est quand même pas mal de
protectionnisme
ils ont une commission nationale de
vérification des normes des autres
est-ce qu'on est assez vigilant
s'agissant de l'invasion de certains
produits en France et trois
ils font des choses que je trouve
intéressantes qui sont des ce qu'ils
appellent les centres d'innovation
manufacturières qui c'est toute la thèse
du Vivier du vivier de compétences
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a en
France un problème de Viviers de
compétences et en particulier pour
redonner goût à des techniciens des
ingénieurs etc et eux ils font des
centres de Viviers de compétences vous
avez vu sans doute celui de l'Ohio sur
le 3D et tout ça je trouve que c'est une
façon de mobiliser l'opinion autour de
plantes filières assez intelligentes
donc en tout cas sur le hors-cou parce
qu'on se focalise beaucoup mais on a
l'air de penser qu'il y a pas d'autres
moyens et c'est faute de ces autres
moyens que le problème du coup du
travail apparaît comme un des éléments
sur lequel la puissance publique peut
agir donc je me permettais de vous
interroger sur sursaut c'est autre
monnaie
alors peut-être qu'on ne va prendre que
deux questions parce que les questions
de Madame une manne ont été assez
nombreuses peut-être celle de Monsieur
Montesquieu et ensuite on fera une autre
série
me pose un problème parce que je n'ai
pas su décelé de divergences
c'est pas uniquement dû à une origine
commune du Sud-Ouest un amour partagé du
rugby mon ex en extrapolant vous propose
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas une dramatique
erreur de stratégie
et de la part de l'industrie française
et de la part de nos dirigeants sur
beaucoup trop d'années et est-ce que on
a été est-ce qu'on n'est pas à la traîne
d'autres pays comme l'Allemagne souvent
cité bien sûr mais aussi l'Italie mais
aussi la Corée du Sud mais aussi de
Japon mais aussi l'Inde
Bangalore en étant le meilleur exemple
et peut-être la Chine qui je crois
commence à produire des produits de
grande qualité donc est-ce que
l'inversion de cette stratégie
et qu'on est forcément conserve mais
forcément aussi sur une longue durée ça
peut pas se faire en trois ans
peut-être et est-ce que l'État n'aggrave
pas cet état de fait en privilégiant
comme vous l'avez souligner les bas
salaires est-ce qu'il ne faut pas au
contraire viser une très haute qualité
par des très haut salaires et une chose
qui n'a pas été si tout à l'heure on a
abordé à peu près des charges est-ce que
le fait que les charges soient
proportionnelles au salaire
de contribuer
aussi à faire cette modération qui fait
que aujourd'hui avec la mobilité qui
peut exister au niveau international les
leads
qualificatifs les gens les plus
qualifiés ne vont-ils pas chercher bonne
fortune ailleurs on abordait un peu le
problème des investissements la taxe à
75% me semble un message dramatique qui
va aussi dans dans
le même sens
même si c'est un sujet autre et ça sera
dû ça se traduit par une baisse
abyssale des investissements étrangers
en France est-ce que tout ne
contribue-t-il pas aujourd'hui à
abaisser le niveau de la production un
niveau où on n'est pas on peut pas être
compétitif parce que c'est surtout le
coût qui est qui intervient on peut pas
être compétitif avec des pays avec des
salaires à 200 ou 300 euros donc
est-ce qu'il faut pas réviser totalement
cette politique industrielle et aussi
inciter les industriels à choisir
d'autres créneaux
je ferai juste de petites remarques
peut-être très brève sur ce qu'a dit
Madame linmann pour alimenter un peu le
débat en ce qui concerne les aires les
aides sur les filières on se souvient de
sinistre mémoire quand même des aides
sur les charges sociales type acquitex
où les entreprises ont déjà obligé de
rembourser enfin etc
oui mais j'étais dans une entreprise qui
a
oui oui mais j'étais dans une entreprise
qui a dû rembourser à l'époque c'était
assez douloureux et et simplement
quelque chose qu'on a peut-être pas
évoqué qui est cher à Madame la
rapporteur on parle souvent de
l'investissement
donc dans en termes de compétitivité
l'investissement matériel mais il y a eu
il y a aussi l'investissement humain en
termes de formation qu'on a peut-être
pas qui qui est intéressant
bon c'est très vaste
bon madame la sénatrice
le
leur coût vous avez évoqué leur coup et
l'action du commissaire général
investissement
effectivement
c'était notre travail et c'est le
travail de mon successeur lui ou je
faisais
je pense que
bon j'avais été au début un peu
sceptique lorsque avait été lancé le
grand emprunt je me dis un pays qui est
déjà 13 endetté qui lance un grand
emprunt pour financer l'innovation la
recherche etc est-ce que est-ce que
c'est vraiment approprié j'ai changé
d'avis peut-être d'ailleurs parce que
j'ai bénéficié de concours
il faut quand même être honnête mais
j'ai changé d'avis parce que je crois
que
emprunter surtout dans les conditions
actuelles pour financer l'avenir ça a du
sens parce que même du point de vue
financier le taux de retour pour la
collectivité de ces investissements à de
très bonnes chances d'être supérieur au
taux d'intérêt qui sera payé et donc je
pense emprunter pour financer l'avenir
ça a du sens ça a plus de sens que
d'emprunter pour financer les salaires
des fonctionnaires bon mais mais
c'est bon donc je suis et en plus
travaillant ayant travaillé deux ans
dans ce commissariat de manière que j'ai
trouvé absolument passionnante je ne
m'attendais pas à trouver autant de
d'intérêt de plaisir à ce job que j'ai
quitté avec beaucoup de nostalgie pas de
regrets parce qu'il faut avoir mais
nostalgie
je
crois qu'il ça va dans la bonne
direction dès lors qu'on sort incapable
de maintenir le cap qui est de financer
l'avenir et de pas se substituer au
budget de l'État
et ça c'est la grande difficulté en
période de d'économie budgétaire chaque
ministère qui est
enfin j'allais dire étranglé c'est
peut-être exécif mais enfin qui qui a
des difficultés vient voir le
commissariat pour demander des crédits
en substitution de ses propres au
crédits budgétaires qu'il n'a pas donc
je pense que ça ne doit pas être le cas
il faut privilégier la recherche
l'innovation l'accélération du passage
de la recherche à l'innovation le le
travail interdisciplinaire des centres
de recherche je travaille en commun en
partenariat entre les centres de
recherche et l'industrie entre les
grandes entreprises les petites
industries c'est tout ce que fait le
commissariat et je pense que ça va dans
le bon sens je le disais notre objectif
c'est d'accroître le niveau de la
croissance potentielle du pays
et à quoi conscience potentielle en
allant vers le haut pas en pratiquant
une politique à l'espagnol où on baisse
les coûts où on fait de la dévaluation
sociale fiscale et de tous ordres pour
gagner de la compétitivité je pense que
la France a capacité par sa base
technique par son sa base de recherche
de trouver la compétitivité par le haut
dans encore une fois dans dans la montée
en gamme c'est ce que vise le
commissaire investissement et je trouve
que
globalement il accomplit bien sa tâche
et qu'on commence à avoir le premier
effet le problème c'est que c'est une
affaire de 10 ans
c'est une affaire de 10 ans
et on en s'appelle le dire mais on a
perdu cette compétitivité en 10-15 ans
on va la reprend pas le retrouver en 2
ans je rappelle que l'Allemagne le plan
l'agenda 2010 de Schroeder c'est 10 ans
avec trois majorités politiques
différentes et deux chanceliers de bord
opposés qui ont mené exactement la même
politique
ça vous donne une cohérence une
persévérance dans l'action
qui
est à mon avis indispensable
alors ensuite vous avez évoqué
on aurait pu faire mieux que les 30
milliards c'est la question qu'on se
pose chaque fois
je suis
je crois qu'il était il est important de
faire les deux d'avoir des politiques
qui s'adressent à un certain nombre de
filière je reviendrai là-dessus parce
que il faut le faire avec doigté
et en même temps je pense qu'il fallait
faire un
créer
un événement
et je souhaitais moi qui porte sur les
allocations familiales parce que
j'estimais encore une fois que c'est son
des dépenses qui relèvent de la
solidarité nationale donc plus de la
fiscalité
même si je sais qu'il y a un vaste débat
sur le sujet mais je vous ai expliqué
mes raisons et je pensais que c'était
quelque chose qui pouvait
recréer de la confiance
nous verrons si c'est le cas
la BPI
alors avec les 30 milliards dotés la BPI
moi je trouve que la BPI a fait plutôt
un bon démarrage
c'est un outil qui
asseusement d'ailleurs ne suscite aucun
débat idéologique je
constate que tout le monde est à peu
près convaincu que cet instrument
manquait surtout surtout avec un secteur
bancaire qui mène encore sauté par des
règles de prudentiel qu'il empêche de
financer assez largement aussi largement
qu'il pourrait le souhaiter l'industrie
les balles 3 c'est pareil d'ailleurs
pour les compagnies d'assurance avec son
incidieux qui ou qui les empêche de
d'intervenir massivement fonds propres
sur
pour les fonds propres des entreprises
donc je crois que c'est un instrument
utile
je pense qu'ils doivent démontrer que
c'est qu'il y a une montée en régime on
peut pas tout leur donner il faut il
faut assurer une montée en régime de la
BPI elle se met en place elle a elle a
même pas un an d'existence je rappelle
qu'elle date du 12 juillet 2013
et donc les récentes il faut qu'elle
crée qu'elle se qu'elle crée son
savoir-faire qu'elle accumule de
l'expérience et je pense qu'il faudra
organiser sa montée en régime
sachant qu'on peut elle peut pas aller
très loin parce que d'abord c'est une
banque elle est souillée réglementation
bancaire et deuxièmement il faut faire
attention qu'elle est dans l'oeil du
dans le collimateur de la direction de
la concurrence
de Bruxelles donc il faut donc aller
elle est quand même très elle peut
elle a des contraintes dans ce qu'elle
peut faire
vous avez évoqué la relance de
l'industrie
manufacturière ceci étant dit les
investissements de l'avenir d'autres la
BPI pour lui permettre d'intervenir
justement au fonds propres dans les
entreprises de faire des préverts il y a
un certain nombre de de d'éléments de la
politique de la BPI qui sont alimentés
par le commissariat et d'ailleurs nous
avions un petit débat avec la BBI pour
savoir comment tu es assuré la
gouvernance de ces financements nous
souhaitions une annonce partagée et que
la BPI ne considère pas que cet argent
lui appartenait mais enfin c'est un
autre sujet
relance de l'industrie manufacturière
moi j'ai trouvé intéressant l'initiative
de d'Arnaud Montebourg des 34 plans
industriels bon je lui ai dit je trouve
que 34 ça fait beaucoup
mais c'est très difficile parce que si
vous oubliez un secteur ce secteur
ce secteur hurle si vous l'oubliez
pardon déjà indiqué que certains
risquaient
comme il comme vous le dites je peux le
reprendre il a dit que certaines
réponses qu'au bout et que donc il y
aura un effet Darwin darwinien de de sur
ses plans mais le fait de confier ses
plans à des à des industriels pour les
piloter est une bonne idée
j'ai trouvé que certains d'entre eux
pouvaient créer une certaine dynamique
d'autant plus qu'ils étaient assis sur
des travaux de du Conseil national de
l'industrie et le problème ça va être le
financement ce financement va être
assuré par les élections d'avenir faut
pas se faire des lions c'est eux qui
vont c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons je
pense qu'il y a conduit monsieur
Montebourg a souhaité que le
commissariat d'investissement lui soit
rattaché
ce qui ne peut vraiment que de créer de
problèmes et d'autres ministres mais il
paraît que tout ceci est en voie de
solution je me réjouis
sur le protectionnisme
je
n'aime pas cette expression je le dis
franchement je préfère réciprocité
je préfère qu'on considère que parce que
l'expression protectionnisme mais
maintenant
dépasser quand on voit ce que ce que ce
qu'est une chaîne de production
les produits que nous produisons en
France
sont constitués de d'éléments qui
viennent du monde entier
et une partie de ce que nous produisons
en France va dans des produits qui sont
vendus dans le monde entier Valeo Valeo
Faurecia travaille d'abord pour
l'industrie allemande et ils exportent à
travers les voitures allemandes donc je
crois qu'il faut se méfier de des effets
que Coré
le protectionnisme en revanche ce que
vous dites sur les normes
ce que vous dites sur des standards de
sécurité de qualité
ce que vous dites sur le respect d'un
certain nombre de règles évidentes de
droit du travail des enfants etc tout ça
c'est la réciprocité l'ouverture des
marchés publics
peut-on admettre de
voir nos marchés publics ouverts des
entreprises qui n'ouvrent pas les leurs
des pays qui nous des entreprises de
pays qui n'ouvrent pas les leurs ou qui
les ouvrent mal
je pense que cette question de
réciprocité est vraiment une question
sérieuse et peut-être que nous pourrions
pousser à niveau de Bruxelles un peu
plus cette notion même si la France le
fait et si Bruxelles du bout des lèvres
reconnaît le réciprocité mais ne veut
pas s'engager dans cette voie parce que
elle considère que c'est l'antichambre
du diprotectionnisme mais moi je pense
que réciprocité
la différence des secteurs vous l'avez
dit vous-même madame de sénatrice le
il faut il faut le faire avec l'habileté
il faut le faire sans contrevenir aux
règles de Bruxelles c'est la difficulté
du genre de l'exercice vous ne pouvez
pas décider d'en allégement fiscal qui
ne concerne que l'industrie par exemple
c'est pas possible ça c'est pas possible
donc
vous pouvez intervenir en revanche en
amont sur la recherche là oui on peut
intervenir sur ce qu'on appelle le pré
compétitif
les centres d'innovation
manufacturières et bien ça existe en
France ça s'appelle les
ça s'appelle les centres techniques ou
ça s'appelle les carnots les instituts
carnots le Septime par exemple industrie
mécanique vous avez vous avez ce genre
de choses qui sont de l'exemple pour
nous et pris chez dans les instituts
francopheurs en Allemagne nous avons
décalqué les instituts francophones en
Allemagne et je pense maintenant que les
carnots ont pris une véritable densité
non pas l'expérience des francopheurs
ils n'ont pas le tissu de relation avec
les entreprises qu'on les francopheurs
mais je pense que là nous avons commencé
maintenant à avoir l'outil qui devrait
au fur et à mesure acquérir justement
cette intimité avec le tissu industriel
et en tout cas c'est dans ce sens qu'il
faut le qu'il faut le pousser
monsieur demandescue
je suis pas loin d'être d'accord avec
vous
je pense que à force de pratiquer mais
ça mais
à force de pratiquer les les
exonérations sur les bas salaires parce
que on considère que le SMIC étant élevé
on compensa en réduisant les charges sur
les bas salaires
c'est ça ça nous conduit
à
avantagé des industries de main d'oeuvre
qui sont pas obligatoirement d'ailleurs
les industries qui exportent parce que
ce sont souvent c'est comme ça qu'on
fait vivre la grande surface quand même
dont je ne suis pas la poste mais l'état
je pense est capable de récupérer
l'argent derrière donc
oui d'abord les entreprises mais en plus
la Poste traverse une période traverse
une période difficile difficile
la postérieuse je pense que
cette aide n'est pas absolument
sans
utilité mais ceci étant dit je trouve
qu'à force davantage les basses salaires
et on a on a beaucoup de bas salaire
et on a beaucoup de basse à l'air et je
pense qu'il faut trouver un meilleur
équilibre d'ailleurs vous avez cité
des séries de pays
que je pourrais reprendre
l'Allemagne a un système différent d'une
autre sur le plan social c'est-à-dire
que les charges sociales sont plafonnées
à un certain niveau de salaire et le
reste c'est de l'assurance privée qui
n'est d'ailleurs jamais pris en compte
lorsqu'on calcule le coût global pour le
salarié de son affaire et bon
ça remet en cause un des principes de
notre
de
la Sécurité Sociale française qui la
solidarité entre les Français quand même
c'est assez lourd comme décision de ne
pas faire payer les traits au salaire
pour la solidarité avec les plus bas
salaires bon la contrepartie quand même
du système français ce qui était social
c'est que les inégalités augmentent
moins qu'ailleurs et que nous avons un
taux de pauvreté inférieur à celui
d'Allemagne c'est quand même pas
totalement négligeant même si nous
traversons des périodes difficiles
c'est une pauvreté qui est partagée
comme la nôtre c'est une pauvreté qui
est partagée entre les différentes mais
ce sont des gens qui vivent en Allemagne
situation de pauvreté
bon sur donc moi moi je
pourrai revenir votre question je pense
que votre question est valide est-ce que
est-ce que à force de faire des
exonérations sur les bas salaires on
avance pas les bas salaires par rapport
par rapport à au salaire qui apporte qui
apporte valeur ajoutée je ne dis pas que
les autres n'en ai pas mais on a
proportionnelle à son salaire
on maintient on maintient mais vous avez
raison maintient un bas niveau de
qualification donc aucun encouragement à
la formation professionnelle vous je
n'ai pas vous je n'ai pas encore je n'ai
pas encore évoqué la formation
professionnelle mais effectivement une
formation professionnelle qui ne soit
traduirait pas dans les entreprises par
la possibilité de trouver des carrières
qui montent pour les gens pourquoi
voulez-vous qu'ils se forment si c'est
pour rester au niveau où ils sont et
donc je pense que il y a une certaine
perversité à ce système
ceci étant dit j'en parle d'autant plus
que je ne suis pas au gouvernement et
que je n'ai pas les statistiques du
chômage qui tombent tous les mois parce
que quand vous avez choisi du chômage
qui tombe tous les mois et que vous
voyez que sa situation s'améliore pas ou
pas aussi vite que vous le souhaiteriez
vous avez envie de donner un petit coup
de pouce pour que ça accélère et le
moyen de donner le petit coup de pouce
pour qu'il accélère c'est les
exonérations sur les bas salaires c'est
ce que répète monsieur 7
pardon
oui mais
je sais ce que je constate avec une
certaine surprise mais je m'en réjouis
parce que le Président
je crois que non mais notre audition je
veux dire touche à sa fin et je crois
que nous avons encore une question au
moins donc je sais pas
Monsieur daudini Merci monsieur le
Président de donner la parole
c'est un plaisir monsieur Gallois vous
entend parler de la compétitivité alors
peut-être une remarque très vite sur la
Poste beaucoup de ses activités sur ton
concurrence avec les entreprises privées
dans Paris circulent des camions il est
indiqué port de l'être de colis pour
particulier et privé mais c'est pas le
sujet de la question j'étais hier avec
des représentants français allemands
d'une grande entreprise de chimie
allemande qui a des usines en France et
qui intervient en phytosanitaire
pharmacie et polymère vous pouvez
l'identifier alors lorsqu'il a été
demandé à ses responsables quels sont
les atouts en France
deux mots le premier les cerveaux le
deuxième le crédit pour recherche donc
c'est bien à la pluie ce qui a été dit
avant c'est pour ça que je le c'est pour
ça que je le souligne alors ensuite
lorsqu'il aura été posé la question des
handicaps sont cités plus la stabilité
fiscale que le coût du travail ensuite
et cité également une application
Zeller des normes européennes dans notre
pays qui est un frein à l'activité en
particulier je le dis donc en matière
d'environnement et puis ensuite et
également citer comme handicap une
inscription qui serait beaucoup trop
forte dans l'esprit français du principe
de précaution qui fait que le moindre
incident ou le moindre doute génère
immédiatement des peurs des craintes des
polémiques et quelquefois d'ailleurs
génère de nouveaux textes législatifs
alors
parce que Monsieur Gallois il y a dans
les mentalités françaises ainsi
réellement un frein à l'innovation à la
recherche et est-ce que ce ressenti tel
que je viens de le rappeler et fonder à
votre avis je pense que les éléments que
vous avez donné je ne peux qu'abonder
dans ce sens l'instabilité fiscale et
l'imprévisibilité fiscale et puis le
fait qu'on est quand même inventé
l'import de proactif tout ça c'est je
pense extrêmement
déstabilisant pour les entreprises elles
ont besoin d'avoir un peu de
d'horizons de savoir ce qui va leur
arriver même si c'est pas très agréable
elles veulent savoir ce qu'il va leur
arriver et je pense que nous avons là
dans ce domaine un très gros effort à
faire j'avais proposé qu'il y a un
certain nombre de mesures fiscales qui
soient
gelée c'est-à-dire qu'on ne puisse pas
bouger ça a été repris dans le pack de
compétitivité du gouvernement je
souhaite que on puisse s'étendre autant
que possible cette règle de stabilité
fiscale de règles fiscale sociale
environnemental alors j'en viens
à l'environnement c'est à dire
l'application zélée des normes
européennes et au principe de précaution
j'allais dire que je vous me vous me
vous me poussez dans tellement dans ce
qui me donne dans le sens où j'ai envie
d'aller que je j'ai peur de trébucher
j'estime que le principe de précaution
le principal des risques c'est de ne pas
en prendre
parce qu'à partir du moment où on
prendra plus de risques là c'est le
déclin donc je pense qu'il faut que nous
soyons capables de prendre des risques
en les mesurant en les évaluant en
débattant mais prendre des risques
la vie est faite comme ça est-ce que
vous imaginez que pasteur n'a pas pris
de risque le jour ici inoculer le vaccin
de la rage et Marie Curie on est morte
c'est pas
non et d'ailleurs Jacques Attali dit que
l'invention qui a tué le plus de monde
au 20e siècle l'électricité quand même
donc il faut il faut que je sois capable
de de de mesurer ce que ce principe de
précaution peut avoir de de de de
dangereux et et qu'on les mis dans la
Constitution et regrettable je dois dire
que les Allemands sont pas loin d'être
comme nous sur le principe de précaution
mais quand je vois que sur
je veux pas je veux pas apparaître plus
plus méchant que je ne suis mais si je
prends d'un autre technologie
biotechnologies
OGM gaz de schiste nucléaire etc autant
de sujets dont on a plus droit de parler
je trouve que ça fait beaucoup
et certainement il y a d'excellents
raisons mais à force de de se bloquer
toutes les avenues je ne sais pas où
verrou on peut avancer et l'application
c'est les des nombres européennes on
nous dit qu'on est plus avec les autres
et que en matière environnementale en
particulier nous allons plus vite c'est
plus fort que les autres je je l'entends
beaucoup dire de la part des industriels
je vous donnerai seulement un exemple
une entreprise qui s'appelle pas près
qui est assez connue dans le recyclage
le patron de paprik quand je faisais mon
rapport m'a dit sur les 8 premiers mois
2012 41 modifications de la
réglementation sur les déchets
il m'a dit j'ai trois personnes qui ne
font que ça dans mon entreprise c'est
examiner l'évolution de la
réglementation ça c'est possible pour
une entreprise de l'importance de pas
près c'est pas possible pour beaucoup
d'autres entreprises qui n'ont pas la
taille suffisante pour cela et je pense
que nous devons veiller à cela c'est
pour ça que je suis j'avais indiqué
j'interviendrai là-dessus que le choc de
simplification c'est une affaire
politique majeure qui ne peut être prise
en charge qu'au plus haut niveau de
l'État c'est le seul moyen d'y arriver
sinon l'administration française dont je
suis
issu et que j'aime beaucoup c'est une
machine à produire du règlement
formidable et donc elle va elle va en
produire
oui mais il y en a beaucoup trop
mais simplement c'est qu'on madame le
rapporteur a encore une question très
brève et vous lui ferez une réponse très
bref bien sûr
ce que vous venez de dire sur la norme
je pense qu'on pourrait ajouter aussi là
maintenant qui va encore en rajouter
sans aucune efficacité disponible le
dispositif sur la pénibilité non pas que
je sois contre la prise en compte de la
pénibilité vous le savez bien mais ce
qu'on a mis en place alors là c'est
terrible c'est vraiment terrible je
pense c'est pour l'anecdote je pense
qu'on a une très grande capacité à créer
des usines à gaz très très grande
capacité et
moi je voulais revenir sur
sur le petit débat qu'on a eu sur sur le
fait que en fait les l'utilisation des
exonérations sur les bas salaires
finalement ça devient une forme de
facilité même si
moi je conteste je contexte je contexte
aussi ça parce que bon il a deux sur les
masses salaires il y a il y a deux
objectifs
c'est la courbe du chômage et aussi
amener les jeunes non qualifiés qui
sortent du dispositif pour qui accède
enfin à l'emploi
et donc d'abord l'efficacité des sur les
basses salaires à les contesta puisque
le rendement est très faible et vous ne
croyez pas que plutôt que d'utiliser cet
argent public sur cette faible
efficacité il y a pas vraiment un plan
massif de formation intégrateur à mettre
en place consacré beaucoup plus d'argent
et de manière beaucoup plus active pour
justement sortir de de cet impact
intéressé tous ces jeunes qui sont sans
formation moi j'ai le souvenir moi je
viens d'une région du Nord-Pas-de-Calais
avec ses grandes entreprises qui vont
évidemment c'est dans une période phase
puis c'était les 30 glorieuses intégrer
les jeunes dans des centres de formation
à l'intérieur des usines dans lesquelles
ils passaient leur diplôme sur la et où
ils étaient rémunérés qui avaient quand
même un succès qui intégré justement
tous ces jeunes issus du monde ouvrier
et qui trouvaient tout à fait leur place
dans la société je pense que cet exemple
il faut qu'on regarde alors aujourd'hui
l'apprentissage en France
c'est quand même pas terrible je dirais
même j'irai pas jusqu'à dire que c'est
un échec mais j'ai en tête les remarques
qui ont été faites récemment par un
célèbre inspecteur du travail que tout
le monde connaît
qui est Gérard Filoche qui expliquait
que nous contrairement à l'Allemagne
nous nous conservions très très peu
enfin sur 70% il en restait que 40%
parce que les entreprises ne savaient
pas faire
d'abord c'était trop faiblement rémunéré
et que la plupart du temps elles avaient
du mal à ne pas s'imaginer que c'était
une main d'oeuvre à bas prix
madame je viens de donner une interview
Usine Nouvelle sur l'apprentissage je
pense que qui est un cri d'alarme
l'apprentissage a baissé de et la
formation et les contraintes
professionnalisation ont baissé de 8%
2013 et le début de l'année les trois
premiers mois sont très mauvais encore
en baisse par rapport à 2013 alors que
l'objectif était passé de 415000 à 500
000 je constate que seulement 12% des
entreprises de plus de 250 salariés
respectent l'obligation le nombre
d'apprentis qui est prévu légal et elle
préfère payer les les
de le coup
au niveau des branches plutôt que de le
faire elle-même c'est-à-dire que de ce
côté là il y a il y a une déficience
combien de déficience du côté de
l'éducation nationale l'éducation
nationale ne promeut pas l'apprentissage
plus tellement pour des raisons
idéologiques il y en a encore un peu
mais de moins en moins parce que les
syndicats de salariés eux ont viré leur
utile maintenant défendre
l'apprentissage pour
face vous savez aux critiques de
paternalisme etc et maintenant
l'apprentissage est supporté et soutenu
et le deuxièmement c'est que
l'apprentissage apparaît d'une certaine
manière comme concurrent des lycées
professionnels
le le
il y a une inquiétude dans le lycée
professionnel puisque le nombre d'élèves
dans les Cyprien elle baisse en France
donc
il a parlé d'une sorte de concurrence
troisièmement je trouve que
on n'a pas
on n'a jamais manifesté sur l'éducation
sur l'apprentissage une ambition qui
reconduit à un programme national moi
j'appelle de mes vœux un programme
national ambitieux sur l'apprentissage
c'est absolument indispensable et qui
regarde qui comment l'éducation
nationale les entreprises peuvent être
plus actives dans ce domaine quelle
financement et comment on prend en
compte le problème des jeunes apprentis
comment voulez-vous qu'un jeune de 16 à
17 ans trouve tout seul son stage c'est
pas possible sauf s'il a un réseau
familial il n'y a que ça ils ne peuvent
pas se loger parce que
il y a pas de ils peuvent pas se payer
un logement éloigné du logement familial
les frais de transport toutes ces
questions qui sont extrêmement précises
méritent d'être regardé de de très près
et je pense que encore une fois c'est un
sujet absolument majeur je partage votre
avis un homme de mes signes
c'est de l'argent bien utiliser pour
lutter contre le chômage et pour
permettre une meilleure adéquation de
l'offre et de la demande de travail
que l'apprentissage je pense que en plus
ça fait monter tout le monde et il faut
que je le disais l'apprentissage c'est
pas la roue de secours du système
éducatif ça doit être une des deux
routes de vent il y a l'enseignement
général et il y a l'apprentissage c'est
ce qui se passe en Allemagne je vous
remercie monsieur le Président ce sera
donc votre conclusion et nous vous
remercions pour votre parole qui est
toujours parole très forte en matière de
compétitivité merci encore
voilà pour l'audition de Louis Gallois
je vous propose tout de suite de suivre
une autre audition celle d'Henri
osterdignac le directeur du département
économie de la mondialisation à l'omce
et on se retrouve tout de suite après
pour ce qui concerne l'effet sur
l'emploi des allègements des cotisations
sociales les évaluations de l'EFCE sont
plutôt situés on va dire dans la
fourchette basse en raison notamment des
effets macroéconomiques du financement
de cet instrument et dans ces conditions
quels instruments seriez-vous amenés à
privilégier pour l'emploi
et par ailleurs des allègements de
cotisation et des mécanismes de
compensation qui qui en résulte
pose la question de l'évolution du mode
de financement de la protection sociale
et au fil des mesures que nous avons des
facto mise en place
un barème de cotisation sociale
progressif et
estimez-vous que les cotisations sont de
votre point de vue le meilleur outil de
redistribution
et si nous devons faire évaluer évoluer
pardon l'assiette du financement de la
protection sociale
quelles sont les mesures susceptibles de
concilier équité d'une part et
efficacité économique de l'autre voilà
quelques petites questions qui
pourraient servir à votre propos
liminaire et ensuite
madame la rapporteur vous soumettra la
question si j'ose dire et puis nos
collègues donc sans plus tarder je vous
laisse donc la parole Monsieur le
Directeur
vous savez tous qu'en 2007 la France à
atteint un taux de chômage de 7%
on est aujourd'hui à
10,5%, il y a aucun mystère sur les
causes de cette forteuse du taux de
chômage elle résulte avant tout d'un de
la crise économique d'une crise du
capitalisme mondialisé qui
a provoqué qui implosé en 2016
ce qui caractérise
et naturellement ce qu'on a vu en 2007
c'est que cette montée de l'endettement
à des limites un moment donné les
agences autre endettés on a la crise de
ce paille on a la crise des
de la dette des pays du sud de
la zone euro et puis on a le problème
que on a des masses énormes de capitaux
qui sont disponibles qui cherchent une
rentabilité maximale et tout ça ça
provoque une forte instabilité
économique donc on est dans ce contexte
où il est très difficile de la France
face quelque chose à elle seule il
serait souhaitable
que l'Europe agisse mais bon jusqu'à
présent l'Europe n'a pas la volonté
politique d'agir et donc on est
contraint à utiliser des des méthodes
qui sont
qui s'attaquent pas
fondamentalement au cœur du problème il
est évident
que la tentation c'est celle
d'avaluation fiscale c'est-à-dire de
dire dans tous les pays on va réduire
puisqu'on puisqu'on est dans la zone
euro on peut plus dévaluer
donc on va réduire les salaires si on
peut pas réduire les salaires on va
réduire les cotisations sociales
employeur et en contrepartie on va
réduire la protection sociale les
dépenses publiques de manière à gagner
en compétitivité
qui bien sûr est très sympathique
lorsqu'on le fait isolément
c'est ce que l'Allemagne a fait mais
c'est la catastrophe quand tout le monde
le fait
c'est sympathique comme quand
effectivement on peut compenser ça par
une hausse du déficit public ce que
l'Allemagne a fait ce que nous on peut
plus faire
et même dans le cas de l'Allemagne ce
stratégie de 2000 à 2005 c'est traduit
par une croissance extrêmement faible
et donc la stratégie réduction des
cotisations sociales employeur à des
effets médiocres quand un seul pays
l'entreprend et des effets
catastrophiques en si elle est entrepris
à l'ensemble de la de la zone euro
ensuite il y a un petit problème
technique
oui effectivement on a certains
économistes disent oui vous avez raison
mais il y a un Mirac il y a une solution
miracle qui est de concentrer les
réductions du cotisations sociales
l'employeur sur les basses salaires sur
les très bas salaires sur le niveau du
SMIC et là on obtient une élasticité
fabuleuse du de l'emploi au coût du
travail et donc on peut créer
massivement des emplois non qualifiés ce
qui permet de résoudre en partie le
problème du chômage
et donc cette stratégie a été mise en
œuvre de façon massive en France
soutenu par tous les grands économes
tous les économistes français
spécialistes du marché du travail
et ils ont réussi jusqu'à présent à
persuader le gouvernement qu'il faut
poursuivre cette cette dans cette
direction
d'accord regarde les les travaux
empiriques tout dépend d'abord de ce
qu'on appelle l'élasticité du travail à
son coût
qui est très difficile à estimer si la
société du travail est supérieure à un
grosso modo on peut dire
ça vaut le coup parce qu'on donne sans
aux entreprises
ils augmentent la masse salariale d'un
chiffre supérieur à 100
et donc c'est intéressant quand on a des
élasticités qui sont inférieures à un la
mesure est nuisible parce que finalement
autant emplois
plutôt que subventionné les entreprises
pour créer des emplois bas salaires
lorsque montre les estimations dans les
estimations empiriques sont extrêmement
fragiles on s'appuie généralement sur
des vieux travaux américains qui
portaient sur l'industrie et qu'on
généralise au service et donc il y avait
un consensus qui s'établit de manière
administrative pour dire
l'élasticité au niveau du SMIC c'est 08
et puis ensuite ça baisse jusqu'à 0,2
pour les salaires les plus élevés et
donc avec ça
on obtient le résultat que on est une
nécessité moyenne de 0,6 donc le coût
d'un emploi créé en réduisant les
cotisations par des méthodes comme les
exonérations bas salaire c'est de
l'ordre de
34000 euros par emploi créé alors qu'un
emploi public au SMIC c'est de l'ordre
de 24000 et donc on a une
on a des mesures qui sont peu efficaces
ensuite bon se pose la question quel est
cet élasticité que l'on mesure et là
c'est extrêmement contestable parce que
effectivement on peut avoir une mesure
qui permet de créer beaucoup de d'emploi
à basse à l'air donc autre partie le
risque c'est que on détruit des emplois
mieux qualifiés
peut-être moins on se pose la question
c'est quand même ennuyeux de
d'amener vers le bas notre
notre masse salariale il est tout à fait
évident
que lorsque on fait des exonérations
importantes au niveau du SMIC on va
favoriser les entreprises qui utilisent
une main d'oeuvre précaire mal payée
à mi-temps
et au détriment d'entreprises qui ont
une main d'oeuvre
stable avec des possibilités d'évolution
et donc c'est une stratégie c'est une
stratégie risquée et qui correspond pas
aux besoins de la France qui sont de
Montier en gamme et de trouver des
emplois pour des salariés qui sont déjà
qui sont de mieux en mieux de mieux en
mieux formés effectivement
le taux de chômage
des diplômés et nettement plus faibles
que celui des non diplômés mais c'est
pas du tout une caractéristique
française c'est pas du au SMIC c'est
pareil dans tous les pays développés
c'est pareil en Grande-Bretagne
et l'explication c'est l'effet perroquet
les entreprises choisissent lorsqu'elles
peuvent le travailleur le mieux qualifié
pour un poste même si ce poste a priori
ne demande pas des grandes
qualifications
c'est vrai aussi qu'il y a une
différence importante du taux d'emploi
entre les qualifiés et les non qualifiés
mais la France exactement à la moyenne
européenne et toute la politique
d'exonération des bas salaires n'a pas
fait que la France que cette écart c'est
réduit en France plus que dans les dans
les dans les autres pays
donc
évidemment nous avons toujours des
économistes qui nous sortent des études
brillantes dans lequel ils disent en
fait au niveau du SMIC et la cécité
c'est pas 0,8 c'est 2
problème c'est que ça s'appuie sur un
épisode extrêmement particulier d'une
période où les entreprises étaient en
train de débaucher
ça effectivement
à un moment donné les entreprises qui
bénéficient être cotisations de
réduction de cotisation sociale
on crée
40 000 personnes de moins que les autres
le problème c'est que ce que Frank a eu
qui écarcidio c'est une multiplie ce 40
par 20 pour dire
si on polarise les exonérations de
cotisations sociales sur les les bas
salaires on va créer un nom important
d'emplois
mais
on n'a pas le droit de multiplier par 20
une expérience tout à fait particulière
la France a déjà beaucoup d'exonérations
bas salaire et le résultat c'est
ne peut pas être extrapolé à l'infini
et ça pose se développements des emplois
basses salaires ça pose d'autres
problèmes le développement de la
pauvreté dans un certain nombre de
familles qu'il a fallu compenser par le
RSA le le
travail précaire le travail à mi-temps
et c'était etc donc je pense pas que
c'est aujourd'hui la piste qu'il fallait
suivre lorsque il est question de faire
de pacte de responsabilité et de
demander aux entreprises de monter en
garde d'être compétitive de
de faire de la recherche et
développement on a une stratégie qui
était peut-être nécessaire mais
qu'on peut pas prolonger
qu'on peut pas prolonger à l'infini
ensuite vous posez une seconde question
sur le financement de la protection
sociale
qui est une
question délicate vous savez que
dans la protection sociale
ce que je vous dirais très banal il est
convenu distinguer
les prestations contributives et les
prestations non contributives les
cotisations contributives les
cotisations non contributifs les
cotisations contributives le chômage la
retraite les prestations maladie
en espèces il est normal qu'elle soit
payée par les
salariés couverts que ce soit
proportionnelle
aux actifs que ce soit proportionnelle
aux revenus que ce soit proportionnelle
ou
aux revenus d'activité
en ce qui concerne les retraites
personnellement je ne serai pas choqué
si à l'avenir on nous mentait les
cotisations salariales des
cotisations des salariés
de sorte que le choix que pourront faire
les ménages entre partir plus ou moins
tôt à la retraite conserver un niveau de
retraite satisfaisant et bien ça soit
payé par les actifs eux-mêmes et que ça
pèse pas trop sur les sur les
entreprises par contre dans le système
français effectivement on a
on a un héritage du passé qui sont les
cotisations
famille et les cotisations maladie en
nature qui continue à peser sur des
cotisations sociales employeurs et qui
pose un problème de
de cohérence donc ce problème de
cohérence on l'a résolu au cours du
temps parce que on a taxé de plus en
plus les revenus du capital donc on a
les prélèvements sociaux qui pèsent sur
les revenus du capital et aujourd'hui on
peut considérer que les prélèvements
sociaux qui pèsent sur les revenus du
capital correspondent à peu près au
cotisations sociales qui pèse sur les
les salariés
et donc
que le système français qui peut sembler
un peu un peu bizarre et finalement pas
très différent des systèmes à la
scandinave où il y a un prélèvement à la
source extrêmement important
qui couvrecteur à l'impôt sur le revenu
extrêmement important qui couvre les
prestations maladie et les prestations
familles et qui est donc prélevé à la
source et nous bah c'est l'équivalence
et les cotisations sociales employeur et
et la CSG donc du de sorte que toute
grande réforme dans lequel on dirait on
va fusionner les cotisations sociales
employeur la CSG et l'impôt sur le
revenu pour créer un grand impôts
citoyen nous rapprocherait évidemment du
modèle suédois mais
ça changerait pas fondamentalement les
choses
parce que d'ores et déjà les
les revenus du capital contribuent à la
sécurité sociale ça changerait les
choses pour les retraités parce que les
retraités eux ne payent pas de
supportent pas de cotisations maladie et
famille ils ont pas d'employeurs qui
payent des cotisations maladie ou
familles pour eux mais comme on est
engagé dans un processus ou petit à
petit le niveau de vie traité va baisser
à cause des réformes il paraît difficile
de faire une réforme dont le but serait
de baisser encore le niveau de vie des
retraités et donc
on bloque un peu sur l'idée d'une grande
réforme du financement de la protection
sociale favorable à l'emploi
il y a une piste que je peux vous
indiquer mais qui a été qui est
unanimement refusé
qui refusait par beaucoup de monde à sa
consiste à dire mais après tout
les cotisations familiées maladies
doivent être financées par une
prestation qui est de type impôts
les entreprises va bénéficient des
prestations famille parce que ça permet
ça leur permet d'avoir des salariés
qui n'ont pas gardé les enfants et ça
renouvelle la force de travail et
bénéficie des
prestations maladie parce que ils ont
besoin de salariés en bonne santé donc
il n'est pas illogique que les
entreprises contribuent à la protection
sociale et donc
on peut changer l'assiette au lieu
d'avoir simplement une assiette
cotisation ma salariale on pourra avoir
une assiette valeur ajoutée
et donc la réforme possible ce serait de
changer l'assiette des cotisations pour
passer à une assiette valeur ajoutée qui
aujourd'hui est possible puisque on a
créé une cotisation sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises pour les
collectivités locales on pourrait la
faire monter en puissance pour financer
la protection sociale donc c'est
une c'est une réforme qui a souvent été
évoquée qui a souvent été rejetée elle a
des avantages et des mérites elle a
l'avantage que elle permettrait à toutes
les branches de financer de manière plus
égale la protection sociale elle est à
l'avantage de favoriser les entreprises
de main d'oeuvre au détriment des
entreprises trop capitalistiques elle a
l'avantage de décourager la substitution
capital travail le problème c'est que
elle a beaucoup estime que c'est
régressif que il faut continuer à
encourager le fait d'utiliser plus de
travail plus de capital et moi de
travail
donc
je ne pense pas le financement de la
protection sociale telle qu'il est
organisé aujourd'hui est un peu
compliqué mais il est pas foncièrement
et pas foncièrement injuste puisque on
fait payer les revenus du capital
puisque la particularité de la France
c'est que
les salariés les plus élevés contribuent
sur la totalité de leur salaire ou aux
cotisations
famille et
maladies et puis on a un choix à faire
est-ce que on continue ce système où on
assit le
le
financement de la protection sociale sur
uniquement la base Massa salariale ou
est-ce qu'on va sur une base plus large
voilà
je vous remercie monsieur directeur très
rapidement je dirais simplement que
facialement vous convenez que le système
n'est quand même pas spécialement
lisible mais que finalement il reste il
devient juste parce qu'on a établi des
tas de correction finalement qui qui le
rendent pratiquement équilibré mais il
faut dire que facialement c'est pas
totalement de votre avis c'est pas
l'idéal je suis totalement je suis
totalement de votre avis d'accord c'est
pour ça que on a le choix entre deux
réformes possibles la grande réforme où
on dit on va arranger les choses pour
que tout soit bien pour qu'il y a pas de
problème et puis ce qu'on appelle
jusqu'à présent les bricolages qui
aboutissent au même qui consiste à
combler les à tomber les défauts et dire
ah bah c'est scandaleux les revenus du
capital
contribuent pas assez donc on fait un
prélèvement social qu'il y a sur
Internet
donc j'avais bien suivi votre propre
bien je vous remercie donc pour ce
propos très intéressant et je vais donc
passer la parole à notre rapporteur
Michel de Messine qui je n'en doute pas
à des questions à vous poser
moi j'ai bon j'ai bien suivi votre
raisonnement
donc
globalement
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que l'essentiel
de la politique
pour l'emploi et essentiellement et
budgétairement et essentiellement à 6
sur les exonérations de charges sociales
notamment
sur les basses salaires avec une
efficacité
qui est contestable avec des dérives
notamment de trappes à bas salaire
donc il y a un doute important de
l'efficacité d'une aussi grande dépense
publique
alors même qu'on va
la prolonger puisqu'on va passer là avec
le pacte de responsabilité de 20 à 50
milliards
donc c'est une grande interrogation
donc c'est pas le selon vous c'est pas
le bon choix mais estimez-vous qu'il est
possible
d'interrompre cette politique
de manière radicale sans dommage donc ça
c'est la première question la deuxième
question c'est
est-ce que est-ce que le soutien parce
que en fait avec cette politique elle
va vers plusieurs objectifs sans qu'ils
soient d'ailleurs bien défini l'objectif
de d'inverser la courbe du chômage
deuxièmement de permettre aux salariés
non qualifiés
d'accéder plus facilement
au travail et en plus d'apporter plus de
compétitivité
donc
estimez-vous donc qu'elle peut remplir
avec une seule un seul tuyau ces trois
objectifs à la fois ça c'est encore une
autre question et est-ce qui est-ce
qu'il n'aurait pas fallu pour être plus
efficace puisque l'ensemble de cette
dépense publique qui est passée de 16 8
millions sur la première phase à
8 milliards à 20 milliards
est-ce que est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas que
elle aurait dû être elle aurait dû être
mieux ciblée alors pas seulement sur les
salaires mais peut-être sur des secteurs
en particulier je pense
aux petits entreprises au PME qui qui me
semble-t-il ont besoin d'un soutien plus
important ou plus ciblés vers vers des
secteurs d'activités on a bien de parler
avec lui la loi de l'industrie
donc est-ce que la solution serait un
meilleur ciblage même si on sait que il
y a une très grande difficulté parce
qu'on peut pas avec les règles
européennes et aussi non
si
on quel serait
l'alternative à cette politique de
manière concrète et
rapide quoi
que vous que vous préconisez
une autre question je vais la dire tout
de suite
c'est sur le débat autour parce qu'on
parle du coût du travail tout est assis
sur le coup du travail tout est observé
à travers le coup du travail évidemment
et beaucoup disent qu'il y a beaucoup
d'autres paramètres qui entrent en ligne
de compte et cela sont pas suffisamment
observés et après il y a le fameux débat
sur le coup du capital donc qui entre
les qui entre aujourd'hui un petit peu
en ligne de compte qui est entre en
débat sans qu'il y a un véritable débat
sur cette question
au moins un débat public or il nous a
été dit dans le cadre des auditions
qu'il y aurait
des études de l'Insee non publiée qui
conteste justement
la stratégie autour du cou du capital
en particulier on nous a dit que
ce qui pouvait donner l'impression que
qui aurait eu critères entre entre le
travail et capital
viendrait particulièrement du fait que
le poids des dividendes serait
statistiquement grossi
par par la méthode de calcul
des doublons qui seraient imputables à
la multiplication des filiales qui
reverse des dividendes c'est un peu
compliqué on n'a pas été très loin
d'ailleurs on va on va chercher à aller
plus loin sur cette question mais enfin
c'est ce qui alimenterait à mon avis la
réflexion du Gouvernement sur ce sujet
je vous répond à la deuxième question
c'est
c'est plus facile
d'accord
quand on regarde
mais je je peux vous faire passer le
document là-dessus quand regarde
l'évolution du partage de la valeur
ajoutée des sociétés
françaises d'abord il faut faire ça
honnêtement c'est à dire faire ça en net
c'est à dire regarder les dividendes
nets versés par les entreprises en
enlevant naturellement les dividendes
qu'elles reçoivent puisque évidemment la
montée du net la montée du brut c'est
c'est la financièreisation le fait que
les entreprises s'échangent des
dividendes ça on en prend pas en compte
et donc on voit que la part des
dividendes est passé de 3 à 8 % du PIB
si vous comparez l'année 72 ou
à ces dernières années il y a un
phénomène qui explique ça en même temps
c'est la diminution du poids des
intérêts puisque jadis on avait beaucoup
d'inflation donc les intérêts étaient
gonflés artificiellement par l'inflation
aujourd'hui les intérêts sont très bas
et donc jadis les les
les actionnaires bénéficiaient à la fois
de des dividendes et de la dépréciation
de l'endettement du à l'inflation
aujourd'hui ils ont bénéficient moins
donc
une partie du phénomène qui est due à ça
donc on peut corriger le problème que
nous avons c'est que quand on compare
qu'on corrige on s'aperçoit que à peu
près
73 et
aujourd'hui la part des revenus du
capital n'a pas foncièrement augmenté le
problème c'est que les entraves la
croissance n'est plus du tout la même
puisqu'en 72 on avait une croissance de
l'ordre de 4,5% par an aujourd'hui
on est un sac donc le besoin
d'investissement est beaucoup plus
faible aujourd'hui et donc les
entreprises avec le même profit
investissent beaucoup moins
et donc on peut dire comme certains
travaux il a circulé il y a rien à voir
la part des profits n'a pas foncièrement
augmenté de l'autre côté on peut dire
comparer
à l'investissement qui réalise
la part des profits il y a est resté la
même mais les entreprises n'investissent
plus et du coup
c'est trois points quatre points
d'investissement qui nous manquent et
bien ça nous fait un déséquilibre
macroéconomique et ce déséquilibre
macroéconomique quand vous regardez ben
aujourd'hui il est comblé par du déficit
public évidemment si les entreprises
investissaient
les quatre points de pipe qui manquent
on sera en meilleure situation donc on
peut dire les entreprises n'investissent
pas assez compte tenu de leur niveau de
dividende et donc
il faut dire au capitalisme
de manière
ironique on vous laisse le choix
soit
on vous prend vos dividendes soit vous
les utilisez pour investir voilà pour
les exonérations de cotisations sociales
aux entreprises sur l'emploi tout de
suite c'est l'émission politique de la
rédaction de Public Sénat preuve par
trois qui reçoit ce soir le député UMP
de la Haute-Loire et ancien ministre des
affaires européennes Laurent Wauquiez à
tout à l'heure 19h